like one thing that i hate about the
internet right and this is one thing
that i absolutely despise about being an
online creator is that
so if i want to talk bad about something
i always have to preface it before right
and we did this early with the uh thing
with um like me saying like i don't want
to see
uh you know girls dancing
uh that is trying to entice you know
they're trying to
i have to then preface that by saying i
support sex work yeah yeah yeah i i
think it should just should be a given
that that's right
right so that's the way i feel but it
sucks on the internet that i have to
always preface that okay i support this
this this yeah but and i hate that fact
that i i can't just talk i have to then
be like go through the checklist okay i
want to talk about uh uh this
and it's kind of a bad place that they
don't agree with you can't you can't say
anything bad about something that they
agree with
because they don't want to hear it yeah
yeah and you know it's and it's over the
internet especially if it was
impersonally probably a different thing
because that's the biggest thing i've
noticed about speaking online on the
internet and speaking to someone person
to person you like
online you do have to preface a lot of
things because it seems like in person
to person people are more willing to
give you the benefit of the doubt 100
yeah and online people aren't willing to
give you the benefit of the doubt a lot
of the times i think the other problem
as well is that on the internet it's
very much a one-way conversation yeah
yeah so you have to give your entire
spiel all in one go yeah otherwise you
know if they do reply back to you then
it's not going to be this conversation
it's just going to be like shooting the
messenger kind of deal right and it's
like it sucks that on the internet you
know common sense isn't as common as
people make it out like like you know
when we when we say bad things about
japan right that comes from a place of
loving japan and being here for a while
we're here for a reason right we like we
love this place yeah and we love living
here but it sucks that every time
this has only happened to japan in the
uk i never have to say i love the uk
yeah no only with japan do you have to
say i love japan
yeah like because it has this weird
stigma but there's a lot of topics that
you have to do that on the internet you
if you want to say anything bad about it
you have to be like i love this thing
but
yeah and if you don't say that before
people are like
you're against you come from a place of
hating yeah you know yeah and it's it's
so frustrating that that's what it's
become because i feel that there are so
many discussions that are so [ __ ]
bloated because you have to [ __ ] go
through the checklist
of all this [ __ ] nonsense that is the
biggest difference between us talking in
a pub
you like and us talking on trash taste
which we have the same kind of
conversation yeah it's like you put you
put yourself through a buffer
or a
if like there were no cameras filming
it's like like putting on the seat belt
but like there's 50. like the whole like
way way back with the gambling episode
right yeah like i never ever once
thought for a second when we were doing
that episode right this is this is
probably like a quite a well-known
episode amongst the viewers yeah that
you guys were addicted to gambling right
i know you guys you guys are not
addicted to gambling
no point in your life when i say you i
you we never had a vanity
right
you know and it was weird how
because we didn't preface that yeah
because we didn't say because you even
though you guys were playing devil's
advocate to me and i was very much i was
very much arguing in gacha specifically
yeah that there should be more
regulation and that it should be like
that and you guys are just playing
devil's advocate with me right yeah yeah
i know that you guys aren't addicted to
gadgets yeah but it was weird seeing a
lot of the comments just jumped to
conclusions and being like they must be
addicted to catcher because they don't
agree with connor's opinion yeah and
it's like all right you can you can
you can be you cannot gamble and not be
a gambler but also think that catcher
doesn't need any more that's the problem
is that if you don't specify then they
think that you're on the very end of the
spectrum yeah it was just like
you're not allowed to be in the middle
yeah it was just weird seeing all the
comments getting so aggressive about it
yeah like people got like angry about it
and it's happened on a few other
episodes as well yeah i mean i i think
like it kind of happened quite recently
with you isn't it yeah debates oh my god
which like i i think i think we i think
the problem with that was that we were
arguing like two different things yeah
yeah and so it was that was a weird one
that was yeah weird yeah and uh people
people took me out because i was trying
to argue that you know you can have drip
no matter how much you pay for it or how
much is how much the clothes are worth
and you were arguing that you know don't
support fast fashion and you know
try to
you know you try to buy things or buy
clothes that are more sustainable
environment yeah and you care more about
quality nowadays and people took that as
wow conor and joey have just like lost
their way
people like wow color's so goddamn
privileged and by most metrics i am
privileged
and everyone's like you know it was
really [ __ ] weird that was because at
no point in that argument did i ever
argue that that
drip had to be expensive clothes
i my main argument was that the word
drip initially came from you know
high-end fashion when you were like the
rappers who would wear grip and it was
all branded it had to be branded you
know that was my argument and at no
point did i ever argue that cheap
clothes didn't look good yeah but for
some reason the comment section took me
arguing that i prefer quality clothes
not not looks quality like i prefer
stuff that lasts longer yeah i don't
support fast fashion and all that they
were like oh well you know you're all
these fast-fashion all the high-end ones
are using slave labor anyway it's like
well then you're just generalizing it
you're putting them on the bubble
exactly but i never made that argument
right it was it was really bizarre you
didn't you didn't
i i guess the the issue was that you
didn't put that safety net right because
i didn't say i never and at no point did
i say drip has to equal money yeah and
that was the problem because because i
didn't say that people assumed that i
was thinking that people love to assume
and what's even funnier is at one point
joey do you so i watched it joey joked
saying yeah drip is expensive you were
joking though yeah yeah but jerry it was
mainly me people were out here
i was like what is happening and it was
like the whole comment was like conor's
privilege is really showing me he's he's
i'm like what and then like men they
they think with a first world mindset
and i was thinking that like i was like
not from a first world country of course
i'm gonna think i'm trying my best to
learn and to to expand uh my my horizons
and learn more about other countries but
you know i'm obviously gonna think
through a first world perspective like
that's because that's my world right i
don't like is it is it wrong of me to to
have that perspective i'm i'm curious no
because i feel that's the only
perspective but like i'm trying to learn
about other things right
i mean i mean but in the case with that
argument it's very difficult to bring in
a different perspective right like that
right without making no sense i mean i
think the i think the uh argument is
that you know yes do you support
sustainable yeah in a sustainable
fashion um
but a lot of people from third world
countries
can't you know yeah
being able to suspect being able to
support sustainable fashion is in itself
a privilege because right right a lot of
people can't do that right and you know
some people do
at the moment have no choice but to buy
cheap fashion because they can hardly
afford anything else that's completely
okay never hold it against anyone you
know when i was buying those i mentioned
like when i was buying the suit there
was like 30 pounds right yeah that was
because that was all i could afford yeah
right i didn't i didn't get there was no
other option i couldn't i couldn't even
like entertain the idea of getting a
suit that cost a hundred right but
obviously when you're when you're doing
better and you have more income i i do
think it's more of a responsible thing
to do to try and buy things more
ethically that's the thing right like in
that episode you never once said right
yeah yeah [ __ ] your income right my
expensive clothes
i remember seeing this other argument of
like well you know they just overpriced
the clothes etc etc and i yeah sometimes
they do yeah they do but also you know
it's i've had this debate coming from uh
you know doing voice acting a lot which
is a job that takes one hour most of the
time yeah and you get you can get paid
like ten thousand dollars yeah most
people would think that's would argue
that's absurd you should never get paid
that much for one hour of work but it's
the it's what goes into being able to do
it in one hour yeah the reason why i
could do that in one hour is because i'm
i'm trained and i can do the job
professionally i know how to use the
equipment i know how to do everything in
a way where you couldn't just take
someone you get the quality of that
right you get you get somebody who can
do the quality that you want within one
hour in a professional way and it's the
same way with clothes to me like if i
want a suit right absolutely if i am if
i am in a good enough position to be
able to afford a suit that is a nice
suit and i can get it made for me
specifically right and get it because
you know i gotta i have the problem that
i have short legs massive ass so pants
don't scale
like that they scale wide and down right
so normally i i the pants i have to get
like fitted yeah because my eyes are so
[ __ ]
so like that was always a [ __ ]
challenge right i always had jeans that
were either too short or too tight yeah
right and i still have that problem
because yeah you can't get taylor fit
jeans
they
yeah so i i think as well like so if you
were to get like let's say you go to a
tailor right you're paying a tailor who
knows how to do it well he's done this
for like 20 years he's experienced his
whole life he can promise you that he'll
do a good deal it's worth the extra
money if you have the money and you know
you can support a local business if it
is one right i think if you again this
is only if you have the luxury like it's
it's certainly a privilege to be able to
do that and i would never ever get in
anyone's case for not doing that well i
mean i mean i mean if you've gotta you
gotta do what you gotta do to survive
right [ __ ] everyone else right but
that's the thing it's like what i don't
understand is the criticism towards like
how you spend your own hard earned money
it's like yeah yeah yeah it's like i
earned that money myself i'll do with
that money however i please it's like
leave me alone that's a good point as
well like i was like you know you're not
taking care of my finances like why you
can't listen the only the only
questionable decision i make is my jojo
collection right that's the i'll give
you props for that
compare us to other youtubers i think
we're pretty [ __ ] normal yeah i think
so too where is our lambos yeah do you
have a lambo garden
when i rent a car you know like you know
what car i rent a toyota yaris
i love the toyota great car it is a
great coach on that car is fantastic
it's perfect size it's not too big we
don't even own cars
i take the [ __ ] train every day dude
i hate this thing where people are like
they they judge us for what like we're
[ __ ] doing with our lives and it's
like bro just like i i don't come to
your house and be like really hot
pockets cringe bro yeah you got cheese
puffs
like what is this i
i don't know yeah because because like
you're going back to what you were
saying about getting paid for like doing
an hour of voice acting getting paid
like a certain amount that voice actors
do get paid and i i
give this example to like every artist
right or every anyone working in that
kind of field which is you go to you
then you have to ask the client then
okay so would you rather pay the same
amount for me to do this work in
five hours or in 10 hours to get the
same amount of work um
and if they say yeah or no then
then you then you can say that okay so
i'm being punished for doing my job well
efficiently right in this time period so
you'd rather pay someone else to do the
same work
for more time even though
even though you're paying them for like
you're paying for the same amount of
work but you're paying them to do it
less efficiently than you yeah but like
the perception is that because you're
doing it
this well you're giving them the same
amount of work for a shorter period of
time that you're charging that much and
that's that's just how the industry is
you know yeah you're not you're not just
paying for hours worked in you're paying
for skill as well and skill is part of
the pricing that you pay absolutely and
also you know when it's these big
advertising companies in what realm is
it fair for your voice to be plastered
over say mcdonald's all over the country
yeah yeah it's a branding issue as well
yeah like it's it's it's they're using
your voice so you you have a certain
right to to sell that whatever the earth
right exactly there's a lot of jobs like
that like you know like like art design
graphic design modeling yeah anything
you know it's if it's if it's uh
although like stuff like voice acting i
100 admit like it seems very easy from
the outside but to be able to do it
consistently and perform
what the person wants and be able to
adjust and be able to do it all
professionally it's very difficult over
and over we get called back you can
build a reputation you've still got a
long way to go man there's people who
are much better than me yeah yeah who
can do it but you know at the end of the
day you you want to make sure everyone's
getting the right right yeah and it's
yeah it's it's uh it's one of those
tough decisions money is always one of
those topics that is so polarizing
depending on uh what's going on you know
and uh where you're from and your just
your opinions on it like you know um
i've had people uh close to me who
have been like very critical of me
earning money doing what i do
yeah and they they've been like well i
do i do x thing like uh i i do ex thing
that's more um contributing to society
so i don't think it's right that you
would get paid more than me and that
whole argument i absolutely despise as
well yeah because it's like what can you
say to that that will get them to
understand right yeah it's like if
you're if you're if you work in like
medicine or something and you firmly
believe that that you are
doing something more important i would
argue you are doing exactly more
importantly you are but but that's just
that's just business that's how it is
this is how it works we don't make up
the rules i i think there are jobs that
are far more important than the jobs
that we have now like absolutely the the
fact that teachers get paid what they do
i think
[ __ ] tragic [ __ ] atrocious yeah
absolutely and i think they should like
get much better pay yeah and but it's
also like you got to do what you got to
do make your own bag you know what i
mean like i'm
world doesn't do any favors that's not
something we can do anything yeah man i
i i will advocate for change and i i
will do what i can from my position
uh but also
bro this economy's right
you know
you know you know you know it's bad when
it's like yo what the [ __ ] that youtuber
can afford a house yeah
this guy just makes videos what world
are we in where like now being wealthy
is you can afford a house yeah exactly
like i'm i'm trying to secure my future
because i don't know how long this shop
likes exactly
i'm trying to do well while i can you
know and i i would never criticize
anyone who is trying to do what they
need to do uh to succeed in life
if you're not [ __ ] over somebody do
what you need to do yeah you know like
as long as you're not active hurting or
ruining someone's life you do what you
gotta do to get by and um you do what
you need to do man i i firmly believe
that
whatever you wanna do don't hurt anyone
go go for it